Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: no using SCPs to
affect the outcome on American Idol, or any
other reality show competition!
Previous violations of this rule have included:
showing his least favorite
American Idol contestant
SCP-096’s face in the hope that it would
hunt him down, sneaking SCP-348 to a Hell’s
Kitchen contestant, and releasing SCP-049
into the house on The Bachelorette because,
quote, “None of them are good enough for
Rachel, so they all deserve to die.”
Dr. Bright is to be reminded that, if he cannot
stay on his best behavior and stay out of
the competition, his tv privileges will be
revoked.
And does he really want to risk missing the
latest season of Love is Blind?